Behind the walls of a sign less abandoned looking warehouse in Tel Av-iv is one of the most thrilling fine-dining restaurants you'll ever find
the fresh high-quality ingredients
The amusing energetic atmosphere and the open kitchen where you can watch every dish carefully prepared from start to finish our
Reasons why this restaurant is known to be the best high-end dining experience in Israel
Get ready, I'm taking you with me to eat an unforgettable meal at Tel Aviv's ha salon
We made it to the restaurant look at our seats right in front of a big pile of meat and vegetables
See all of them cooking I love how they just set out all of the fresh produce
There's even some figs and some cherries
Just whole stalks of green onions and just a pile hunks of meat just sitting on the counter top before us
This is a fine dining restaurant, but at the same time it feels like you're eating in the middle of a market
and it's owned by Al Shani who has he's a
Legend in the food scene in tel-aviv. He's a food scientist
He owns a number of restaurants around tel-aviv, but this is his flagship restaurant
It's only open two days a week and it almost has like a laboratory feel to it. They slice things with expertise
Everything is down to a science and the ingredients are the top of the notch
There's there's no better quality ingredients for the first bite. They've sort of served us some
Pepper bread like a focaccia type of bread their tomatoes on and there's some sage
It's like perfectly gooey, but then that cream is so silky smooth
Next up we have FIGS carpaccio
And he very very thinly and very delicately sliced up big figs laid them onto a plate
And then I think all he topped it was with is some salt some pepper some
And he he actually pounded the pepper so it's fresh
He cracked that pepper open, and then there's olive oil on there, and then some peas
some Parmesan
Wow, this is just a beautiful beautiful dish
It's just absolutely pretty
Well and the figs are just incredibly soft and tender
Just that light sprinkle of probably sea salt that cracked black pepper the olive oil kind of brings it together and
Then just just only enough cheese to barely taste it and give it a little bit of saltiness
There's just so much going on in the kitchen here. It feels like you're in a food movie fantasy
The next dish that has come is a crab and they just
Meticulously de L bet crab. It's mixed with just some very light
Ingredients I think some very light herbs. There are some sprouts on there, and then there's some raspberries to accompany it well
I'm gonna try to get a bite with some of the crab, and I want that raspberry as well
That crab is just melt-in-your-mouth and then
There's almost like I think use some of those green onions that are sitting right in front of us
but they're so mild and then that raspberry are just like the purest raspberry I've ever tasted next dish is a
Shrimp bagel, but it's like a superior shrimp bagel
They use crystal shrimp
And he peeled the shrimp he he just like so delicately so carefully the chef he layered on tomatoes
Thank you
He leered on pickles, and then he layered on that shrimp, and then there's it's saucy and it's their own version of a bagel so
You're gonna grab this
All man Paul you can feel they're like juiciness in your hands boozing with good flavors
Oh, you can feel how soft and supple that is
Okay, I can't wait any longer
Well that's ridiculous the shrimp
Is amazing and it's like a like a creamy sauce and then but I can also taste, and there's the refreshing dill
So I'm just dripping all over the place, but it's so good
Introduction is the gumbo surface of my lemon okay?
This kitchen is just so entertaining
I'm just actually standing
I'm standing
I'm not even sitting and I mean I'm just at the edge of my toes watching the chefs work
Though one of the main dishes has come leave it up to duty to reorder the entire rack
It's lamb right yeah, because I know this way
maybe
If we had them order it in the first place
It's already sold out so they only have my curiosity the whole restaurant for a nice
so you pre-ordered it definitely sold out now, so
before you
If I came right out of the wood oven and you could see it that the ribs were actually alive still they were
Pulsating it was like there was it was Bert. It was it was beating and you can see those juices just oozing okay?
I can't talk any longer
It's just it's just utterly tender. It just slides. It just slips oh
Look at that
It's just dripping with juices and just fall apart tender while that's hot too
Thank you sir, thank you
All right, I'm going in for this he's and look at just look at that the prettiness of that carmelization
That is caramelized beauty
That's in your mouth
Nobody knows
How to handle lamb
The ocean is closed so much research for Lam
Just perfect
I'm gonna use that bone. Just to kind of scoop up some of that meat below there and look Paul
Oh, it's so so lamb oily perfectly specific on the back
Vegetables you see oh yeah
I
Wow
That is ridiculous that is unbelievably delicious you're gonna want to lick your fingers after every single bite
Okay on second thought I will use my spoon because it's so sloppily
Tender down there that I think is a must
Just pretend its own juices. It's in its own juices
We're having one final dish it's beef carpaccio, and then he brought it over to our bar counter table
What he did was truly amazing he he took a metal mallet and just pounded it into a paper fit
It just spread out until like at least four times its size
And you can just see that me like squishing out of the bottom of the mallet
Oh, and by the way, it's Robbie hey, I think that's some some basil on there
I have a soft place in my heart for Rafi
Just got back to the apartment after dinner that was
the most fun and unique
High-end fine-dining restaurant experience that I've ever had in my entire life. I just sat there in awe watching them cook
It was like if it was like an amusement of culinary
like
experimentation it was it really was like a culinary lab a couple things quick things that you should know is that number one the
Restaurant, it's quite a lively restaurant, so they have two sittings
They're only open for two nights per week
and they have two sittings the first setting is more calm you can sit and you can converse the
Second setting you got to know is very lively
It's kind of almost like a nightclub experience they turn the music loud people start to dance
So just keep that in mind number two is that it's very expensive
Our total bill came to 1,000 around one thousand three hundred shekels for
The dishes that we had and that's just Dave Annette and I eating so huge. Thank you to David Khalifa
He's the hungry tourist on Instagram
And I'll leave his link on in the description box
You gotta follow him for some of the most amazing food throughout the world. I want to say a big
Thank you to you for watching this video. Please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
I'd love to hear from you in the comment section below
thank you so much for watching this video and
Yeah, that was such a such an honor to to have a chance to eat at that restaurant